on the left that's it's the sister right
yeah I'm a 70 show yeah they were all
like that this shot is that her now no
that's not true
Erick sister from that 70s show is still
not doing well why does she have Mac in
my eyes yeah what the I'm pretty
sure she died oh man
died yeah what happened it looks like
she got exposed to the atmosphere of
Mars yeah come on give her you had to do
the three we weren't able to get to the
reactor in time yeah she looks like as
the reactor before the airs let him yeah
right before the right before ah they
found there look at her oh yes she died
in 2013
oh man what happened to her well it says
she can be stopped
[Music]
I brought some Colorado pot I got some
back to New York I'll just say that and
how's your butthole doing recovering all
right okay you had a barrel a weed yeah
I took it I took it I emptied out of a
giant dildo and filled it for weed they
offered it to them in like something
that had like you know a point on it so
it can like go in and dance it no I want
blunt I want a blunt force mm-hmm you
want to stretch around a flat surface I
believe what I said is I want a Wiley
coyote it and just sit on it yeah in a
Wiley coyote fashion you got a home and
uh you know the barrel they put her on a
st. Bernard's neck yeah up his ass no
point Lube
blunts I'd set it straight up and down
breathe into it I squatted down
give you the name of the guy that does
the seminar in San Diego touches you to
breathe open your asshole name's jorden
something sweetheart sweetheart of a man
can get you to fit up anything up your
butt we were saying coke earlier the
e-rate es coke phase that we were
imagining you going through I saw this
week and I was outside smoking a
cigarette at my hotel and Buffalo lovely
Buffalo New York and a guy was out there
it he looked like a 90s Latino drug
dealer I was whirling up giant oversized
like leather pal a pal jacket and yeah
it's like the winter hat on his jacket
matched his jeans they were very tan
everything was tan on him and his boots
he's walking around upset because he
says his hotel my confirmation they had
a hot tub room for me man hotter I go
okay which by the way I had a hot tub
room you're in a fireplace we had a hot
tub and a fireplace in your room
fireplace was awesome
wait but you had a hot tub yeah not like
a big bathtub like a hot tub filled with
water not a hot tub no a jacuzzi tub
jacuzzi tub
yeah I think it's what he was saying -
okay yeah he's saying they don't have it
for me he's just outside he's upset he
goes i neva worried about me I'm worried
about this pig I got in the car which I
thought was an interesting way to put it
Wow
romantic I wonder where this pig I got
in the car and then he go I see
and pull a bag out of his pocket yeah
this is so Britt there is security
around there is hotel staff around and
he goes uh yo you want to bump to you
you want to do bumps to you yeah Sammy
here's you want to do bumps
I went hi I'm okay man thank you and he
goes well I'm little man
don't mind me goes I'm having fun this
night no matter what and I've never seen
this before I told Christine I was so
blown away but he reached with three
fingers into a pretty big bag of cocaine
and grabbed like grabbed cocaine with
his fingers yeah and then just sloppily
like put it under his nose and just
started snorting and it was just all
over his face and that's the coke
version of putting water in your hands
and drinking it dude he's just like so
obvious he almost made like that he did
like the LeBron the chalk throw at the
beginning of the game it also sounds
like the lake and like a child would do
coke like how do you co can you like you
just grab it and put it in your face yes
there's no like you have to shove it
into your nose with your hands yeah
there's a certain thing of coke I like
that if I ever did coke I'd want the
ring that opens up and you go oh yeah
just get yeah he's like me I'd
wanted I'd want to bang I want a
diamond necklace with a little spoon on
I'm gonna grow a sick ass
fingernail like a vampire fingernail oh
absolutely
just a realist at just get in there and
doing Gummer's blast it up yeah
yeah for sure yeah I'm lucky where I
wasn't living in mesh in 72 because I'd
be dead by 1980
last night me and Christine dropped
Isabelle off at home in Long Island we
were driving home we were having such a
good time in the car listen you know
we're not in our car a ton Jamie now
play music Sunday night drive yeah no
traffic no traffic we're the hottest
back out with mom you back you two back
on the prowl written but in the car yeah
so funny the week they got that
car when we came to your house to watch
Joey Logano take it all they're like
people not we're not smoking in there
you'll never ever smell it buddy I am
all over that car meticulous didn't feel
like our car until we smoked in it
you've but while we are cars best parts
the best place to smoke in the world is
the world it's the thing it's the place
I miss smoking the most when you're in
the car for the first day we gotta warn
in it for seven hours on the way to
Philly we did I think we only smoked one
cigarette oh but how good this one feel
smoking yeah good job evil people who
yeah so we were driving smoking sir
literally singing along me and Christina
going 18 I get confused every day hey
put that over the background this is
Bert Kreischer asked story me and
Christine are having such a good time
singing along with this and then get
interrupted by its Bluetooth to the car
yeah so the song gets interrupted by
Jacob atop calling and being Christina
feeling good we got ya guys I think
windows are down so we're smoking it's
very windy and loud and we push the
button answer the call and we take it
what's up we're gonna really fly this
week aren't we buddy
I mean legit yeah what's up by Christine
goes this better be good
you're interrupting Alice Cooper and
Jacob it's funny he's bad reception for
whatever reason we're not getting and I
he goes yeah no it's just
you know email came and I know
disturbing the I go hey Jacob what's
going on he's like hold it hold on it
goes he goes there you tell me you know
and we can't really hear you very well
I'm going to and now I mean Christine
are both thinking we found out later we
were both thinking I go it's Jacob
OD'ing Jacobs on drugs Jacobs on drugs
and guys know what's going on he took a
weird mix he had a weird mix and he's
like calling because it's also sounds so
discombobulated so get me out of the
madman and he goes so the mud man's
coming for me please help me wake up
shoot me to space any wings baby
Jamie's wings baby so I start this you
know very disturbing email I got and I'm
still it's kind of loud with the car I
go disturbing evil ego what's wrong we
called me - so I'm like from me like
it's my email I go the ways it please
why is no one trusted I can just tell
the story that I am looking at you
listen this one's jumps ahead is what
she does she's a she's a momentum killer
let's kiss two tongues knocking around
won't change it's just four tickets oh
it's a tire changer he goes I got a very
disturbing I got disturbing you I go
always think I go from who it's like a
horror movie use from you I know
Christine Bale these cigarettes we gotta
roll the windows up and hear what this
is happening positive story right there
now I want to go to Jacobs perspective
Jacob when you call Jay and what I'm not
gonna say what happened when you call
Jane you know it's a dire situation and
you hear Jay the greatest day of his
life
was this making you feel crazy it was
Sunday we were eating all day what
did you do that you why I don't want to
get into store I went to a Sixers game
Sixers won Eagles lost but that was a
hell of a season hell of a season good
job see good job Eagles getting back to
playoffs after losing oh yeah official
Nick Foles send-off memorial at
some point but uh yeah and just like but
overall just spent the whole day with
Isabella we had fun we dropped her off
back and well I had a good time
listening to music with her and
everything it's a good day yeah that's
that's what the emotion he got yeah from
you barely cigarettes we're all the
windows not gonna hear the weirdest what
he said that I go for me I start
thinking back now by the way right away
I was going through my head I go advice
um something like weird or something oh
my god was like to voice a voice memo
accidentally on your phone good sense
yes now I'm like what something sent
accidentally that's like weird or
something like I've definitely I can
finally send Christine like dick thing
or send dick pics around or anything you
know I mean like yeah it's not like I'm
like what could this be
and then why would that be disturbing
anywho I'm just like I mean complete
like I'm like what is he talking about
as a mistake Christine's going through
her phone did you get an email no I
don't he just she's great he called me
so it was confusing so then all of a
sudden I was like I'm going into Jay's
sent folder you want me to read the
email no who do you want to read the
email this is what Jacob just says to me
he goes just from you I go I go Jacob
what are you talk I go I didn't I didn't
email you
I've never emailed you I don't think
even I text you I go and he goes hey
baby he goes and all yours he goes says
it's the email saying that you've had a
humongous fight with Jonas who was a big
dog Comedy Central I want to top dogs
one of top dogs
he had a big blowout with Jonas and he
said and I swear in this split second my
mind went from
I was like I said because now I'm like
my thing got hacked yeah something
terrible and I sweat it in a split
second I went it started laughing
hysterically and I go it just took me
back to halftime of the Eagles game
mm-hmm they're still up there up by four
points yeah 14-ton they're up 1410 and
I'm like you know what they're losing
momentum but they're gonna fix it and a
half time they're gonna come back I'm
just alive with hope and promised
already had seen already had seen the
witch with the the Sixers win live
having and and on you and they
go oh halftime of the game and still
looking good we're gonna be good
hey Christine want to go outside and
smoke a cigarette and she goes yeah and
Ari Shaffir goes hey what you guys smell
the cigarettes do you have a lap K use
your laptop for a minute and also I went
in my mind I guess I go had a fight with
come Ari
yeah I go Ari completely and I go Jacob
I don't know what that email says and I
don't want to know yet but I'm just
telling you that that's definitely Ari
Shaffir went into my email cuz like an
idiot I gave him my computer thinking
why would Ari go through my personal
email why would he do that so this is
Fanta and I want to explain it will read
the email in a second I have it still
unopened because he sent it great
now let me tell you he sent it from to
the wrong email address for me that's
hilarious
so he sent it to like a throwaway one
that I have sure and there's a chance to
see it so I didn't see it so I just well
Jacob did see Gianna the only know what
it says yet either needed a while
Kristine read it but this is the best so
Jacob goes I go that was Ari Shaffir I
go watch I go let's go give him his
victory lap cuz he left that grenade I
bet he himself forgot about it already
this is the best part I describes what
our night was so far
spending time with Isabel and everything
all day we call Ari and put them on
three-way with Jacob mm-hmm and I go hey
R & R Joe starts laughing right away I
go dude I just want you to understand
what you did worked wonderfully because
Jacob n rather I described the whole
thing that's described it was an amazing
night we're listening to music and Jacob
calling that's what you sent me the
message he
starts cackling cackling laughing on the
phone and then he goes yeah also just
see no he goes I made it a real teaching
moment I went Isabella you see when
someone hands you an opportunity to do
something like that
so Isabelle completely it didn't say a
word all day completely aware that bombs
laying out there that she's gonna
possibly kill Jacob with anxiety so
funny and pauses when Jacob iowa's aimed
at me too I still know the email says
we're gonna just we're gonna read it
right now on the air and so what good we
have guests coming but they're coming
suppose be here seven nervous
ask you this flex it out so yeah I just
get who do you want to read the email
maybe cuz I I went completely out of
nowhere
Jacob maybe voice we're gonna be so good
because he read it and it like he knows
it's just fear into him yeah and I can
tell by the first line if it is the same
email I got it is okay so it's a group
email perfect he sent it to both of you
that's why Christine when she found out
she panicked and started telling you
which I said sheet by the way that
Christine's anxiety kicks in hard cuz
she starts going into panic mode she
goes what if Dan season and I go what do
you think Dan's gonna do call Comedy
Central before he calls us to be like
what happened Comedy Central Dan Soder I
just got a nasty little yeah
disagreement between so the only words I
heard was got into a fight with Jonas
hey I just have an email that says bad
news is that the name of the
email yeah so Jacobs gonna read it so
why don't we read the email and it he
wrote it I gotta say give him credit in
your style like I could see you writing
like this that's hilarious
it just felt misspellings and you spell
like Corey Feldman because I called my
brother before what the happened
you're saying well you're getting ahead
know what this thing
it starts off saying we just got into a
massive fight with Jonas at Comedy
Central he's threatening to end the
bonfire I'm dealing with it all right
now with with Edie Brooke but if but if
they call you don't say anything
actually don't even take the call until
I get a chance to talk to you this is
really bad so this weekend I
checked Instagram and I got a very long
DM that I was like it was a request I
never checked the requests but I checked
their requests I was like what the
you don't check them once in awhile
very rare yeah you let him bill yeah
check him very rarely so checking in on
my it weird what is this one
there's just long thing and at
first I'm like someone's mad so you have
that reaction of like well what do you
mad about
it was Mads for sure right away right a
key tell right away man
the exclamation points it's like really
because it's because the subject
was you really me on this one
oh dude it and it starts in such a way
that you're like Rd I can tell I can
mentally beat you in an argument yeah so
immediately like I understand they're
mad was like some things aren't funny
yeah a line like that always meet yo
yeah let's have it was just started a
couple of days that out dude this is
just great I'll read the whole email so
then I'm like oh this is
hilarious I scream grab it I try to send
it but I'm like it's like six screen
grabs unless or I'd have to oh how the
message and I'm not allowing the message
and I'll own this dork to get
through so then I check my email and
this lady emailed my website to with the
same message just copy and paste it so I
was like beautiful now I got it in one
slick place where I could read it on my
radio show or as she calls it my concert
so what it is your concerts I did a joke
on Conan and live at Gotham years ago
about Russians being the scariest white
people so in your world tour also in my
world tour called do you think this book
I mean neighbor gets he and I always
used to joke around that was my free
bird it was like the only play Russia
like all wrong no more but I you know I
did it we only call our shows concerts
from now on well let me read the email
and you'll see what she called a concert
in it we call them all yeah you guys
guys if you want to see me live in
concert I'll be dude yeah DC album all
right we're doing a big like we're doing
a big concert where there's a bunch of
different a bunch of different
performers coming up gonna be a hell of
a cop I'm going to do a concert at
frantic I'm gonna be playing on that
concert oh yeah yeah a big concert so
then we're gonna have a thing at the
Comedy Cellar concert hall yeah Comedy
Cellar concert hall it's a big deal it's
a real big deal so I'll just read you
the message just I won't read your name
or anything but this is great
let me get some I get some Russian music
they're good right
dance older couple of days ago my kids
complained that somebody mock them scary
Russian I didn't believe it I live in
Virginia already about three years and
we never ever had these kind of problems
okay I give I think it's it's she's
definitely Russian because this is
written in the broken English of a
Russian do this or are you making like
it's like you make big mistake do and
this is written okay okay I'm not
driving I'm a tree listen I'm a guy I'm
a voice guy I love to shoot it up I love
to bring it more closer to me this is
just straight farm-to-table but
I love it this is understand the accent
and a little bit of parsley on after
today they have to do later I turn on
the radio in my car and understood what
the problem is you created this problem
it was an advertising of your concert on
the radio with quote Russian or scary my
daughter was at the moment in car with
me she started to cry and asked me why
am i scary she is six how I have to
explain it to her how I have to explain
that we are not scary to friends in
classmates of kids to my neighbors to my
coworkers
question mark no I feel terrible
it is insult based on nationality you
are nationalist Dan Soder
stop it you are nationalist not a
nationalist you are now a nationalist
you are nationalist Dan Soder
stop it all caps it was so much -
someone's a nationalist does that mean
they're racist in other nations yeah I
mean that's the kiosk all xenophobic you
go see someone's attacks is that what
like it's the same issed as racist for
sexist yeah it's got an instant it so
never put those things together I mean
maybe it's the dumbest thing I've ever
just said out loud that's okay national
is I called a receipt a recipe you know
what yeah come on like then if I could
clap if I could take these gloves off
I'd clap right now but a part of me yeah
I know if you know I had them sewed into
my skin well she goes on to explain what
she thinks a nationalist is hell yeah
you can't insult and blame people only
because of their nationality
only because they are Russian so
according to you Dan Soder
Russians are the scariest white people
I'm Russian
I've got PhD degree and I speak three
languages learnt well my husband was US
Navy for many years he is a submariner I
mean that's hilarious Submariner yes
Submariner I'm a Russian language
professor here in Virginia and I'm not
scary she's only an English professor
yeah my daughter is six in her classroom
teacher said in her grade report she is
just sweet little girl like she's
writing the grade report against me like
she knows this it's like he's stupid
shithead this is a joke that I did on
Conan eight years ago this is
the best she started to play piano this
year she's the Russian and she's not
scary I want that to be the new
catchphrase Russia she's wrestling piano
it's terrifying a terrified empty house
out and just put a piano with a little
Russian girl playing piano I won't
believe she's not a ghost believe before
I check yeah oh you want another
ghost-like scenario how about this one
my son is 13 he's trying his baby box
insert fully in corner of dimly lit room
wearing schoolboy uniform for many years
ago he sings song and when you try to
listen he turns to scream is he
constantly shushing you and telling you
if you make noise it will get us scary
to you he turns his head backwards and
he stare you in I were you watching joke
dog to death that's terrified you watch
him bite bullet out of his own hand you
find that not to be family boy but to be
scary
watch your back then so do it anyway so
what I'm saying is you'll never know
when I'll strike yeah I'll find you I
think you sleep sleep well on your Sleep
Number how did you know that listener we
haven't had them as sponsors Christine
probably gave you register but to point
home security cameras you come from my
mom you get got uh-huh so it ends like
this I'm just talking about her son
because English is a second language he
loves our dog he is a Russian and he is
not scared he will talk too much which
is concerning but not scary not scary
he says dog is friend and love romantic
not scary not scary
sensual again little of the grid no off
the reservation they say but not scary
different strokes for different folks no
scary I have friends in Richmond I won't
call names she's a student in Richmond
University and he's a doctor
her name is Boris yourself here
her name is Olga I feel like that's an
inertia Swedish he is working at
hospital intensive therapy department
he's saving people's lives every single
day they are Russian and they my friend
from Portsmouth is an optimist as an
operation instead Bank she has very cute
little daughter they are not scared not
Russian or scary you are scary dance of
the scary you are the scariest white man
she said it so it's cred right
now yeah I guess what pinkies you got a
new king and his name is Danny so if you
don't get the words scary written across
the top of your back in crazy gothic
letters oh my god yeah gothic scary the
war do the eyes a knife see ARS are the
A's in the middle you can make the a
something an R key because you can't Oh
so the words so essence see an old crazy
block crazy like shadowing in them yeah
gothic letters and then the a is an
anarchy symbol ran the R and
wire back to the Gothic oh man come get
some come get some of that god I wish I
was the scariest white guy well you know
what chill just a insult but now
I wish I was dubbed with that she told
me I should apologize I've been talking
the fattest guy a girl would that's
pretty cool but that's you can't even
make like acronym that makes that okay
my back yeah why cushion for the pushin
yeah but where's the Anarchy part
where's the Anarchy sign go what are
they use number four ei pushes and the
four is also an anarchy sign
you think your friends would take this
video then share it with them and tell
them to rate and review and you know
make us feel good about ourselves you
tell a friend they tell two friends yeah
it's a pyramid scheme of a radio show
comes the whole thing I got some Cutco
knives also if you're interested oh I
got Spider Cove so come to me if you
want the real one